elon musk is threatening to walk away
from the twitter deal but it's a little
bit more complicated than that in a
letter sent from his lawyers to twitter
they say that twitter has breached their
contract by not providing elon musk with
the appropriate data on spam bots
twitter responded saying we have been
very cooperative in sharing data as per
the terms of the contract which is
legalese for we are not giving him the
data he specifically requested
i think twitter's sabotaging the deal
this note apparently came from their
their their top legal department
it's vijaya gaday who's their head
lawyer who cried
uh reportedly upon hearing that elon
musk would be buying the company i think
it's highly possible that elon in order
to secure the money for the purchase of
twitter needs this data they know if he
gets it he can buy it so they're like
we're gonna do the deal but they're not
giving them the information so this is
where things get interesting elon musk
is threatening to walk away
people uh many people on the left are
cheering for this but they're also
arguing that elon musk never intended to
buy the platform i don't think so we'll
go into this but i think it might be
sabotage it is a crazy news day my
friends milo yiannopoulos is now
interning for marjorie taylor green
okay that's going to be a fun story and
then we have the washington post
suspending veteran reporter dave weigel
for retweeting somebody who made a joke
about women
wow the corporate press is imploding in
the same vein taylor lorenz is being
roasted she's being accused of lying in
her story claiming she reached out for a
comment but she didn't we got to talk
about how the mainstream press lies
about this stuff there's a bunch of
other news we might not get to gas
prices at another all-time high at four
dollars and i think at 86 cents
be still wow guys calm calm i hope we
can get through this one it's gonna be
scary
well joining us to talk about all of
this is brandi cruz hi thanks for having
me it's nice to get a break from seattle
absolutely well thanks for coming uh who
are you what do you do um i am who am i
i'm the human to two dogs and a cat
the girlfriend to a really sweet man
um and secondary to that i am host of
the undivided podcast i
am a survivor of the mainstream media i
left in november after 10 years
as a journalist in the most soul-sucking
place to be a journalist in the country
the city of seattle i'll fight anyone
who wants to argue with that um you
might if you're not familiar with me i
was there through the 2020 stuff you
might have seen my crew be mobbed out of
chop the occupied protest zone you might
have seen my awesome security guard
disarm some
uh riders of stolen police rifles uh
shooter rugi and then i decided to leave
after the november election for a
variety of reasons but i launched the
undivided podcast which i call political
commentary for the anti-fringe cool yeah
thanks for hanging out yeah luke is back
how in the world are you still living in
seattle
welcome back beautiful and amazing human
beings it's good to be back of course
the bilderberg meeting was happening in
washington dc as soon as i heard that i
went i dropped everything i had had a
friend drive an rv up drove up here and
of course i had to cover that event and
it was absolutely crazy linda's already
grabbing the microphone i don't speak up
darn it there's also some strange guy
sitting across from me i don't know who
he is lots of things are going on things
are getting very intense and uh yeah if
you want to support me you can on
billgatesmeet.com that's an official
website that i have commemorating this
awesome shirt yes if you go to
billgatesmeet.com
you could go there and check out the
video that i did about the infamous
pregnant women meme that we have decided
to digitize and put a picture of uh uh
mr bill gates himself um i don't think
it's working bill gates bill gates
did you not set it up right it's set up
i was just working for me to like meet
or maybe like meet you meat
m-e-a-t like the fake meat that he keeps
uh things have been very crazy and i
think they're only going to get a lot
crazier from here so it's good to be
here yeah we got sheamus brandy great to
have you on uh luke
i'm seamus coughlin
uh we just launched a website this year
louis are you here
i'm here because you got scared and ran
away i don't know someone couldn't
handle it i don't know what you're
talking about the old man retired to
florida now he's back but you know what
they say out with the new and with the
old you older than me great to be back
everybody
we're happy luke's here so i run a
channel called freedom tunes we upload a
video every week sometimes twice a week
we also just launched paywall
freedomtunes.com become a member for
five bucks a month you'll get an extra
cartoon each week plus behind the scenes
content and you will be helping fight
the establishment by supporting
independent content so luke came up and
took the ireland that's right artwork
and put in the garbage he literally did
which a fan spent quite a lot of time
making luke and you disrespected him as
well as an entire nation of people
it smelled like potatoes and whiskey to
be fair i understand yeah i didn't know
what to do with it and clearly it was in
the wrong position it was in the wrong
way
it was in the right place neither of
those things are bad smells exactly
great no he was he was getting old
sitting there smelled like chickens too
anyway wish me luck corralling this
crazy crew tonight i'm very excited to
have miss brandy over from the left
coast stoke to hear about seattle
hopefully i'm sure it can't be any worse
are you stoked to hear about seattle
yeah well we can okay it's just far away
far away okay i want to hear something
different but i'm excited for tonight
let's get into it before we get started
head over to timcast.com and become
members to help support our work as
members you'll get access to exclusive
segments from this show we're gonna have
a members only show up at 11 p.m tonight
they are not family friendly we speak uh
uh
we're impolite
we swear a lot you know don't you know
what your kids listen to this but uh
support our work and you can watch these
it really does help and you'll be
supporting our journalists of which we
have just hired the wonderful adrian
norman is on the show a couple weeks ago
he's fantastic we're excited about that
hopefully we'll have him out here
joining us on the show soon we want to
hire more people expand and we've got
some crazy plans for culture jamming
with your support we will do the best
and most fun marketing that uh you will
ever see
but don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends let's jump
into the first story from cnn business
you know we love cnn we do cnn reports
elon musk threatens to walk away from
twitter deal interesting choice of
headline depend uh based on what the
story is it's a lot bigger than that
they say elon musk issued his most
direct threat yet to walk away from his
purchase of twitter on monday openly
accusing the social media company of
breaching the merger agreement by not
providing the data he has requested on
spam and fake accounts
in a letter to twitter's head of legal
policy and trust vijayagade musk alleged
that twitter is actively resisting and
thwarting his information rights as
outlined in the deal this is a clear
material breach of twitter's obligations
under the merger agreement
and mr musk reserves all rights
resulting there from including his right
not to consummate the transaction and
his right to terminate the merger
agreement
now twitter apparently issued a response
saying that they have been very uh very
cooperative in sharing information as
per the terms of the agreement
that just says to me that they're not
giving him what he wants now a wall
street journal story said that uh musk
had stated he needs the data in order to
secure financing i'm wondering if the
people backing this deal the 19
investors outright said we want to know
how many spam bots are on this platform
before we give this money because if it
turns out it's twice or three times or
even four times as high as twitter
remarked we're going to see our value
plummet could you imagine if you
invested a billion dollars in twitter
and then the next day they're like
here's the disclosure it's actually five
times
more spam bots there's gonna be you know
how 20
the company just going to drop by that
much value so they're saying no
i don't know exactly but it seems to me
like they're trying to stop elon musk
that makes the most sense not that elon
musk isn't trying to buy it or tim it
could be the twitter employees who want
to continue to work from home and only
want to work two hours out of the week
or whatever they're doing because
because again there's a huge disconnect
between the employees at twitter the
whole establishment that is twitter that
has used this kind of information
highway for political purposes twitter
is extremely biased it has been using
its platform for political purposes for
corporate purposes for the benefit of a
lot of powerful people who wield that
power and i think the the bigger core
issue here is that probably twitter has
something to hide that they don't want
the general public to know it could be
the number of fake accounts because
there could be a lot of governments a
lot of corporations a lot of celebrities
propping up spam bots propping up
narratives and agendas in such an
artificial way that it would shock the
entire system if people would find out
but it's fascinating and also not
surprising how the mainstream media and
you mentioned that headline is choosing
to spin it because you've given
two now really legitimate reasons why
this is on twitter's end because elon
musk is asking for information
if they give him the information and
it's under five percent then he's gonna
he'll have no excuse but to move forward
with the deal and so i just i laugh this
articles from ap it says that uh this
has led some experts to question whether
the billionaire wants to use his loud
complaints to negotiate a lower deal
price or even walk away entirely he's
asking for the information if if it is
what they say it is give it to him and
then he won't walk away yeah release it
make the internet more accountable more
accountable more transparent why should
powerful people use fake accounts in
order to promote illusions that aren't
real uh reality that's an important
aspect here because we have to
understand here governments have been
creating fake accounts to push war
narratives exactly well it's also to
manufacture consensus right and we saw
this with a report that we were talking
about a week or so ago that about half
of joe biden's followers are fake which
is hilarious right because we're almost
certain given how coherent sounding the
tweets are that joe biden is not running
that twitter account so you have
a non-president running a presidential
account being followed by a bunch of
non-followers
i don't get though why even if twitter
is admitting that it's under five
percent it's admitting there's some
number of bots why wouldn't twitter
purge any bots because if you can
identify the bots
i think they did that so the day after
the deals announced we see progressive
and celebrity accounts drop dramatically
oh they whined about it too and
libertarian conservative skyrocketing
following count uh my my
personal view of this
it is probable i'm not saying i have
evidence or anything i think what may be
happening is that twitter often talks
about the health of the conversation
there's that there's there's a i forgot
it's it's there's a law on the internet
that any sufficiently unmoderated
platform will
become right-wing i think twitter was
becoming dominated by the right
so twitter intervened and started
suppressing right-wing voices and
creating fake accounts to make it seem
like the left was more prominent than it
was
that's my that's my that's my thought on
what may be because then the day after
the deals announced it just flips
there's and they said it was organic
there's no way katy perry's 200 000
follower loss or whatever mate it makes
no sense people are like i'm a follower
katy perry but now that elon musk might
buy the platform i'm out i don't buy it
no and you got how many more followers
in three days 100k 100k they were
unbanning people
they were they were unbending people had
been long since banned so i think they
were manipulating something let me let
me read what twitter wrote because we
have this over the daily mail it says
quote
twitter has and will continue to
cooperatively share information with mr
musk to consummate this the transaction
in accordance with the terms of the
merger agreement we believe this
agreement is in the best interest of the
shareholders we intend to close the
transaction blah blah blah look at the
first sentence
twitter has and will continue to
cooperatively share information
notably absent from that statement was
we have complied with mr musk's request
to provide the data requested to help
facilitate the transaction
that statement as they publish it says
to me they're denying elon musk the
information and they're using weasel
words trying legalese to make it seem
like they're actually complying lawyer
talk i hate lawyer talking i hate people
who talk in these kind of weird vague
terms because you know they're up to
something they're trying to be nefarious
in some kind of way and and again musk
is claiming here that they're
withholding the data that this is clear
material breach and there's a one
billion dollar clause whoever walks away
from this deal is going to have to pay
for so uh this is going to be very
interesting i think this is going to go
to court i don't see any of these kind
of companies walking away i see a lot of
uh posturing because i do think the the
the scary things in the closet of
twitter are absolutely terrifying and if
we did find out what was happening i i
think people's jaws would just drop to
the floor because there is a lot of
potential it is ripe for abuse it has
been abused what we know publicly
probably is still just scratching the
surface to the bigger agendas and the
bigger uh games that are being played
that we don't even know about there was
a report back and i think 2012 leaked
information showing that the us air
force was trying to buy sock puppet
accounts
so that they could use them in foreign
countries to create the perception of
popular narratives
so if you look at countries it is
believed that they were doing this in
libya i remember during the arab spring
particularly during libya it was
interesting because some of my hacker
buddies said how come so many libyans
speak north american dialect english
on twitter they were noticing and the
response was many of these people who
are on twitter are on twitter because
they were western educated before going
back to twitter which makes sense yeah
one of the first countries that started
doing this is israel they started openly
talking about this this was in the early
2000s there was mainstream news articles
about literal government israeli
employees that were sitting there behind
the computer sending out particular
narratives sending out particular
arguments and also cass sunstein obama's
information star even talked about how
he is going to be
utilizing the internet as a way to make
people look crazy who criticized the
government create fake accounts to
promote fake theories in order to
destroy any legitimate criticism of
government cass sunstein obama's
information czar look that up this is i
remember confronting cass onstein
one-on-one face-to-face about this and
he said i never wrote this i never did
this the the document literally has his
name it's it's published in
peer-reviewed journals uh and they were
lying through their teeth they were
talking about these and this in the
obama era what are they doing now man
you can only imagine so if let's operate
on the belief that twitter is trying to
kill the deal with elon musk do you
think it would be because they are
trying to hide what would be revealed if
it went to elon musk or because they
want to continue to control the
narrative on twitter why not both or
both yeah or they just don't want to
work i want you to pick one because elon
musk wants people to work wants people
to come into the office he's going to
change the culture and it could be that
these employees are like
crazy you saw what elon
said to tesla the other last week or
whatever that everybody has to come in
for a minimum of 40 hours
otherwise we'll assume you've resigned
i'm sure all the twitter employees saw
that and immediately started screaming
and crying and rolling on the floor we
have to work i feel unsafe here this
doesn't work no he said if you want to
he said if you want to work from home
you have to also work from the office
for a minimum of 40 hours a week so the
suggestion being any overtime you can do
at home but this this is a big story i
mean i mean elon musk uses twitter in a
very specific way now twitter is
claiming that there's only five percent
uh accounts on that entire platform that
are fake that are spam accounts that are
propaganda government accounts corporate
accounts whatever it is
musk is claiming that it's over 50 now
that's a huge number that's going to
change the evaluation of twitter but
also make people think maybe what i'm
seeing online maybe what i'm seeing in
the algorithms isn't really reality and
the way that elon musk has been
harnessing twitter recently is
absolutely amazing i've been critical of
him with neurolink artificial
intelligence him trying to connect human
brains to the internet but when he when
he called out the doj for not leaking
the epstein-galen list holy cow did he
send an important message to the power
establishment that he's not playing and
he's willing to reveal information to
the general public that would open
people's eyes about what really happens
in behind the true seat of power ladies
and gentlemen i would like to take you
into a time machine to the year of 2012.
rs technica reports
reddit founders made hundreds of fake
profiles so site looked popular in its
early days reddit was built on lies sure
lots of code but some lies here's how it
works you make a social media platform
but nobody's using it
you then need to convince people it is a
place to communicate and share ideas so
what do you do
you operate hundreds of fake accounts
and whenever you get one person to join
you respond to them you upload them you
follow them they all of a sudden feel
like wow i'm i'm getting a lot of
engagement on this platform imagine this
you create a social media app
you market it to high schoolers
when they sign up you give them a
thousand or two thousand fake followers
those high schoolers are not going to go
to all their friends and be like i got 2
000 followers on on luke luke chat and
they're going to be like you have 2 000
followers yeah because i'm famous and
then these other kids are gonna be like
i want to be on luke chat and be famous
they all start signing up you got to
talk about bill gates only you give them
all fake followers then they're going to
be you're still doing tick tock dude
i've got 10 000 followers on loop chat
and they'll start switching over and you
will fake the community that's what
these companies do that's the low level
that's that's a small level of what
they're doing what governments are doing
it's even far more sinister far more
complicated especially when it comes to
galvanizing people's political opinions
because when you're able to show
a majority of people that this is what
the herd thinks this is what the herd is
people are going to go along with ideas
if they think a lot of other people
believe them and you could do that
politically you could you could do that
socially you could do that with culture
and i think that has been slowly
happening ever since social media
started to be used because we're talking
about just a few years ago it was it was
it was declassified it came out that
that facebook was talking about
engineering people's emotions through
their algorithm they were experimenting
on it exactly that were unsuspecting
people that weren't participating in a
project didn't know they were
participating in a project but they were
testing if they can make people sad if
they can make people happy that is
god-like power and authority that is
absolutely unaccountable crazy this is
what what facebook was doing years and
years ago what's twitter doing right now
with with it's information highway i
mean man it
you
i don't think no one's
you know facebook their their algorithm
knows when you go to the bathroom yep
they know when you poop
they know your friends they don't even
have facebook twitter makes me sad
already yep i don't know if they have to
do an algorithm to make me sad twitter
already makes me sad and i cannot look
at you because i just get a pregnant
bill gates looking back at me
he's making eye contact with you right
now pay attention
but that's technically not pregnant bill
gates that's just bill gates as well no
we put his face on there i know i know i
know it's just his gun
but it was a picture of him with a big
belly in the blue shirt it happens when
you eat fake it's looking sweet right
now
that's why we like he tweeted this image
uh not this image exactly but but the
pregnant emoji so he's he's he's playing
and
again bill gates is attacking him
through secret organizations uh and
nonprofit organizations that are trying
to also pressure twitter and advertisers
to make sure that that they're going to
pull their money if elon musk does buy
it there's a lot of things that could
happen with elon here because if if
let's say 50 of the accounts are fake
he's going to be laughed at like oh they
got the best of him they stole money
from him and twitter is going to lose
popularity because people are going to
be like no one's using it so so this is
an important this is make it or break it
when it comes to twitter so elon musk is
making a very big move here a lot of
money uh he's putting his money where
his mouth is will twitter give the
information give up the data that's
another question that we need to answer
i want to jump to this story here this
is breaking news cnn recently announced
they're not going to be saying breaking
news but this one is from cnn business
the washington post suspends reporter
david weigel over a sexist retweet
okay now before we get into this i would
like to shout out senator ben sasse who
said that weirdos are running the
political space it's an algorithm driven
by rage and he's half right
but he's not completely right there are
weirdos running things but it's not the
french this is becoming mainstream
politics don't believe me
dave weigel
retweeted a joke on twitter probably
he's probably sitting on the toilet he's
probably like look at his phone he's
like it's a joke
oh what's that that's funny retweet
anyway what was i doing and then all of
a sudden a bunch of women at the company
starts freaking out saying he's sexist
and now he's suspended from his job this
is a guy who's reported on on seth rich
he's report i mean
this is this is a high-profile political
reporter with 600 000 followers who's
been suspended for retweeting a joke on
twitter he didn't say anything to us to
his co-workers just retweeting it this
is twitter being the real world
i can't imagine what it's like to work
at the washington post oh and also don't
forget we got the story about taylor
lorenz lying about these youtubers so
here's the sh do they i wonder if they
have the joke on uh
you look that up but this is my first
response to this from all the treachery
from all the horrible things that the
corporate mainstream media has done wmds
banker bailouts lying through their
teeth
putting innocent people at the fray
because they they smirked uh
lying libeling destroying people's
livelihoods going to grandma's homes
because they opened up a facebook page
doxing individuals this is what you
punish them for a retweet of a joke are
you kidding me this shows you the fake
nonsense bull crap that is really
happening behind the corporate media i
mean you worked you worked in the
corporate media you probably know pr and
hr and all this other stuff that happens
behind the scenes but why do you think
this happened why would they why would
they punish him yeah was it really the
outcry or is it them just trying to out
woke that well you know to me and do you
want to read the joke well i want to
have it actually no we cannot read this
on air it's funny it actually it
actually says oh i was like you can't
so the joke was quote every girl is bi
you just have to figure out if it's
polar or sexual
he retweeted that
felicia sanmez had recently had a
discrimination lawsuit against the paper
dismissed
a decision her attorney has said she
plans to appeal
there it is so they're trying to protect
their their bottom dollar i mean that's
what it comes down to but to me what
felicia did fully in her name of course
has to be felicia what felicia did after
this
is worse and when you're talking about
the actual culture of a newsroom and
having worked in mainstream media
newsrooms can be very
challenging places to work but i and
i've worked in really toxic ones but if
i had an issue with something that a
co-worker tweeted and i'd had co-workers
who had issues of something i tweeted
they walked across the room and they
told me about it or they picked up the
phone or they sent a text so felicia
gets on there and shames publicly
her co-worker for retweeting this and
then i don't know if you guys saw this
uh jose del rio he also works for the
washington post he called her out on it
on twitter and he's basically like hey
you know said essentially what i said is
if you have a problem like go talk to
him but this is toxic to be calling him
out on twitter so he's since deleted all
that and i feel so bad for this guy he
he put out a tweet saying last night i
came under an unrelenting series of
attacks intended to tarnish my
professional and personal reputation the
cause some tweets i sent calling for
compassion within our workplace and so
he talked about all the attacks and he
briefly deleted his twitter account took
it down over it yeah and he works at the
podcast so you made a very good point
about the fact that if you were working
at a news outlet what you would do is
speak to someone who said something
offensive to you unfortunately i and you
know this is just my own perspective
they haven't said this but i would
venture to guess that their goal was not
to have any kind of problem solved it
was just to grandstand and from the
public and virtue signal and show
everybody how put upon they are having
to work for this news network how
difficult their life is the question is
would you rather have a co-worker who
retweets offensive things in their off
time or a co-worker who will smear you
in front of the public without ever
having a conversation with you about it
prior that's why wait wait wait worse i
got a better one for you or would you
rather have a co-worker who fabricates
the news ladies and gentlemen i would
like to pull up this story from
newsdiffs.org
our good friend dave weigel deserves to
have been fired five years ago not
suspended over a sexist retweet why
because dave weigel effectively
fabricated a story about seth rich
essentially accusing kim.com of trying
to hack gmail to plant false evidence
news diffs shows that the original
article on may 24th 2017 was edited
november 18 2017 and completely changed
i'll give you the simple version
first the image i'm showing the green is
the latest the red is what removed
what weigel was trying to insinuate was
that because seth rich's gmail account
received an alert from mega.com
that means in all likelihood kim.com was
trying to hack the email to plant fake
evidence in reality people on 4chan had
posted that they signed up they put
sethurdge's gmail into mega to see if
they would get a ping back for an
existing account this triggered a
welcome email to go to the email account
and then the washington post fabricated
a story i reached out to dave weigle for
comment he didn't correct it until
several months later without notice and
without an editor's note or a correction
the story just changes completely see
they don't fire people for things like
this
now what's fascinating about this is
think about how this impacts things like
wikipedia this story will be used as a
as a factual reference to kim.com
hacking gmail or trying to and they'll
cite the washington post who six months
later will change the story but
wikipedia won't change
these people
are
what's the what's the right word you
know i feel like
evil
is is going easy on them den of scum
lords yeah so you know what dave dave
you should have been fired for this
your your institution is garbage taylor
lorenz deserves to work for the new for
the washington post and everything
coming their way it's exactly what you
deserve jeff bezos is a scumbag he
bought it congratulations on your trash
investment yeah i would argue one of the
signs and one of the most obvious
straightforward signs of a failing
system or society is that the mainstream
institutions are no longer operating in
accordance with their purpose so the
dominant media culture in this country
has been pretty dishonest for a very
long time this is not a recent
development but the fact that somebody
who works for the media which is
purportedly there to expose us to
important truths would not get in
trouble for publishing a story which had
fabricated information in it or tried to
insinuate things were some other way
than they were in reality
the fact that that's acceptable he
doesn't get in trouble for that but he
does get in trouble for this retweet
shows not simply that it's the case that
this institution is no longer operating
an important in accordance with what its
purpose should be but also we can detect
what its new purpose is or what they are
attempting to go for which is to promote
a woke left-wing narrative and because
he failed to do that he was fired well
it's all fruit from the same poisonous
tree i mean it all has to do with that
obsession with virtue signaling i mean
that's why their reporting is so bad
that's in part that's why they're
reporting it so bad and that's why they
would fire him over something like this
i got i got to read you some of this
article you guys are going to are going
to laugh all right so here's what
happens
mega dot co dot nz that's kim.com's
website you may know kim.com from mega
upload way back in the day
so this is mega.cod.nz it's a news it's
a new zealand top level domain the dot
co dot nz right that so so here's what
he writes
the latest is the original article the
latest revelation that a hacker from new
zealand may have been trying as recently
as this week to hack into rich's email
offered fresh evidence the conspiracy
theory is false dot com it seemed may
have been willing to create a fake
archive of emails from rich to prove his
role in the dnc leak
he changed to say
someone may have been trying to hack
into rich's email offered fresh evidence
the conspiracy theory is false the
family worried that com or someone eager
to prove him right may have been willing
to create a fake archive of emails from
rich or crack a password to see whether
rich had passed on documents with a mega
account
just because the email came from.nz does
not mean a hacker from new zealand but
instead of issuing a correction an
apology and retracting the article they
stealth edit it six months later they
say nothing now if you go back to the
article it's all cleaned up these people
are scumbags well that's like that elon
musk article that which is like it was
new york times right where it talked
about tried to somehow tie him to
like the racist
uh history of of south africa and it was
really odd i mean they totally went
through and scrubbed it and rewrote it
so it was softer because the way they
had written that article initially about
elon musk made it seem like he was his
family and he was like racist and all
this stuff and then they rewrote it in a
way that distanced him from uh from
south africa and from apartheid yeah and
this is the crazy thing these are the
authoritative sources these are the
sources that that big tech social media
uh runs in their algorithm youtube
twitter facebook they promote these
accounts these individuals these lying
scumbags and and they get
no accountability no transparency and
this is the only time that they get
punished for for retweeting a joke it
it's a joke in itself and it's sick and
it's no sad joke no corrections on this
article i have it right here here's the
actual argument that stands now it says
may 24th 2017 but as i showed news diffs
which i believe is defunct show that it
was edited in november of that year
here's the best part a couple other
mainstream reporters retweeted the story
as fact they retweeted the story right
kim.com did do this and when i reached
out to them they said they effectively
told me to screw off one guy
he i think he worked for buzzfeed a year
later said i must have missed this sorry
i'll take the tweet down it's what they
do a year later they they publish
conspiracies lies and fake news and then
no one fact checks them here's the best
part
newsguard we use newsguard on all of our
sources right yeah we like news guard
but here's the funny thing if the new
york times says it's true newsguard just
assumes it is and then if you get
evidence proving new york times wrong
they'll say you lied because these
people are all in one big
circle of jerks where they give each
other awards for fake stories like
russiagate and then never investigate
and never give the awards back they do a
lot more sicker stuff behind the scenes
but that's another story family-friendly
show i'm not gonna go there i knew some
journalists a lot of them are just drug
addicts
pill poppers
manic depressants and just absolutely
insane people that will do anything for
a buck essentially the corporate media
is pr for the establishment this is the
perfect representation of it this little
drama thing shows you the perfect
representation of our current media
state that it's filled with absolute
nonsense um and that and that's what it
is and i think these stories need to be
proliferated i think we need to talk
about stealth editing i think we need to
continue to remind people that hey when
you're watching the news you're watching
an agenda you're watching something that
rich people only want you to understand
and know just think about what is okay
at these newsrooms a stupid joke is a
suspension-worthy event publishing fake
news don't worry about it we'll sweep
under the ruining a child's life just
because he smirked intentionally
suppressing the episode story exactly
right you know
having having victims come forward in
the 90s to you say hey there's this
powerful man with an island doing
unspeakable things to me and all these
thousands of children and just looking
all the way and not reporting on it
absolutely disgusting behavior writing
the story making the story editing the
videos and then
not publishing it when you have
according to cbs news according to the
project veritas people like bill clinton
that you got him when it comes to this
bigger uh story surrounding a mr epstein
again
lots of bombshell stuff that that could
help humanity but the reason we can't
have nice things is because of the
corporate media that's my perspective
yeah well i i want to make a point here
there's this old idea or this line from
solzhenitskin you know the the line
between good and evil runs across every
man's heart one thing i'd like to impart
to anyone in the mainstream media if
they happen to be listening or would
take any of what we're saying seriously
is that if you want to talk about
combating misinformation right well the
war between misinformation and truth
also runs across everyone's heart
everyone's capable of lying for their
agenda everyone ideally should want to
tell the truth for their agenda
unfortunately it's not the case if you
are so concerned about misinformation
and disinformation spreading
and you think that there is just a flood
of unfounded conspiracy theories and
people don't trust the mainstream media
like they shouldn't so the traditional
gatekeepers are gone maybe don't stealth
edit articles that were promoting
misinformation as if you were telling
the truth the entire time if you are
concerned about the fact that public
trust in the media has eroded you need
to look in the mirror and figure out
ways to improve it's not our fault it's
not as if the media was doing a great
job and then people started making a
living in in making a career out of
working in alternative media you guys
dropped the ball now people are looking
to other sources and you're jealous of
the other sources and you're hating them
instead of trying to figure out what
you're doing wrong one thing i wanna say
about jeff bezos i'm gonna make a
prediction i think he's gonna say
something about all this
i think he's gonna i think he's gonna
say something negative about his own
paper about this he's been a little he's
been kind of
coming i mean he said the things about
the white house about inflation elon
musk comment was pretty interesting yeah
he's been he's been saying more things
um that surprised me on twitter
than he has in a long time and so i'm
gonna make a bet that i think he's gonna
say something negative about his own
paper about all this i hope he does
we should he's probably gonna be
partying taking steroids and just
hanging out and not giving not caring
let's talk about some narratives real
quick we have this story from newsweek
yuvaldi mom who saved kids from school
shooting says police threatened her have
y'all seen the video of the mom who went
in the building
giving an interview and explaining what
happened
i will tell you this the conclusion is
simple
either intentionally or inadvertently
police helped the shooter in uvalde yeah
that is not with it that is not being
disputed right now so when people came
out and and slammed the police
because they were standing in the
hallway for 70 minutes at this point
everyone said it was incompetence these
people are cowards but then when this
mother says the police actually stopped
her inside and tried and and they tried
stopping her while she was already in
the building
you have to wonder
if there were people in the building
trying to get in the classroom this
mother and the police not only were not
going in but they were even stopping her
and others and this only ended because i
believe it was a cbp tactical unit that
defied orders and just breached the
building the cops there
i would presume we're just accidentally
helping the shooter heaven forbid they
knew it was happening and said no no
we're gonna let it roll out nobody would
i'm gonna totally reject that i don't
think that that is what happened but i
do believe that it's gross incompetence
i am someone anybody who's watched me
knows that i'm very pro-law enforcement
pro-good law enforcement as i think we
all should be but i don't think there's
any excuse for what happened i'll also
note the u.s marshals lied about this
they blatantly lied about it you know
they denied handcuffing any parents even
though immediately there were videos of
handcuffed parents on the ground this is
may 27th 8 58 am us marshall's official
twitter handle additional u.s deputy
marshals were asked to expand and secure
the official law enforcement perimeter
on the school deputy marshals never
arrested or placed anyone in handcuffs
while securing the crime scene perimeter
that's a lie they tasered parents right
this is the insanity why give also why
give them the benefit of the doubt right
we should about
benefit of the doubt about what they're
saying number one and and two this
entire saga and event i think it's
possible they were waiting for the
shooter to to run out of ammo and they
were lying through their teeth about
every aspect of this it's not out of the
realm of possibility to say that they
were aiding and abetting at this point
when we know all the details here
because how long what's the time frame
here why are there so many unanswered
questions about this very specific event
and and this mother came and said some
very important things that contradicted
the official police story once again
they can't get that story straight they
keep lying through their teeth and when
you look at their actions they arrested
handcuffed parents tasered parents
pushed them away set up a blockade and
they told everyone on the news there was
no active shooter it wasn't an active
shooter information why what information
did they have that provided that
information since there was kids inside
of the school literally calling them and
with the dispatchers with their radios
we're telling them it's still an active
shooter situation children needlessly
died because of these police officers
direct intervention that killed children
this is not the this is not the truth
there's one child shot bled out died
specifically because
after 40 minutes there's another officer
that allegedly said said say something
if you're in the room and you need help
said something the killer shot them this
mother came out and she said two very
important things one that there there
was an active shooter situation that was
going on for a lot longer than the
police said said it was and two when she
first came in there she said that there
was no police officers inside but they
did try to stop her outside so what in
the world were they doing why would they
give the orders not to go in when
specifically they were getting
information from the radio saying it was
still active they said they said that
they thought it was not active what
evidence did they have giving that
information they won't provide that
there needs to be some serious questions
there needs to be some accountability
put these people on a stand right now so
we found out so we find out what
happened because the blood on those
children's hands i mean they're
responsible for it whether you like it
or not and
this this whole back to blue crowd needs
to really understand the true realm of
what happened here because it happens a
lot
real quick she's she's uh the threat was
that she said if she spoke up she would
be charged with obstruction of justice
if she spoke up outside in the moment
after speaking critically about the
incident of the media gomes said an
officer threatened to charge her for
violating probation on an unrelated
charge for obstruction of justice
disgusting abuse of power i mean that
right there shows you that they're
trying to cover up and silence critics
of them
pathetic punks abusing their power fire
all of them right now all of them should
be fired and and they should be
disgusted for their behaviors
i want to be very clear about the back
the blue crowd i believe that the way
that this is handled absolutely was a
travesty and a tragedy i don't believe
there's any excuses for what happened
they had a dream now they had a drill
practicing this weeks ago i don't
believe we have before excuses and they
had an ai program that they literally
had trying to prevent this they were
training inside of that school days
before the shooting march yes yes march
yeah yeah yeah days march 26th they were
training
to prevent and stop a mass shooting and
then their plan in action was stand
outside and and attack and taser and and
handcuff parents this is
what i just want to make clear that i'm
making a distinction about intent i
don't believe there's any officers that
have the intent to allow someone to kill
children intentionally i just want to
make a distinction that i don't believe
that that's what happened i'm not saying
that i don't believe that they their
actions led to kids dying that shouldn't
have died so if the cops are there they
have protocol to storm the building even
if you're a single officer that's what
the protocol said and they all stand
outside for what was it 70 minutes
i i like i think you can argue what you
mean by intent but like
yeah they were they were like okay with
him doing it that's that's the thing
they were okay with it absolutely it's a
fact like you can't stand outside
hearing the gunshots go off like they
did
and beal and like and pretend it's not
an active shooter situation and lie
through their teeth my point is they're
standing outside hearing the gunshots
for 70 minutes and they were like no no
no
yeah it means they were fine with what
was happening inside now i i i
understand there's going to be like we
can get to a semantic argument what it
means to be fine sure i'm not saying
they were like high-fiving each other
i'm saying they were like it is
preferable for me to stay here then do
anything to help these kids when it
comes to a business that opened up when
walmart was allowed to be open months
before that they were tough guys they
came in there they shut down grandma's
small business a kid wasn't wearing a
mask in school they dragged him out of
school handcuffed him arrested them in
many instances a parent had a baby that
that wasn't wearing a mask on a plane
they were all tough in the enough in
that time but when it came to children
children losing their lives calling them
talking to them as it was happening this
is this is what you have to understand
here about this event they were calling
they were talking to their dispatchers
dispatchers were telling them hey
there's kids inside they're bleeding out
they're dying they're still being
continued to shot and your decision is
like oh it's not an active shooter
situation we're not we're just going to
stand back here well it's in dispute
that the 911 dispatch calls were making
it to the officers my understanding is
that is in dispute and there was some
belief that the guy who's now in hiding
like didn't bring his communications in
and wasn't relaying it i'm just saying
what i know and what isn't is not
confirmed but i do agree we're probably
semantics i think we're in the same
position that where i stand on this is
officers could have saved children's
lives and didn't now whether anyone
wants to put intent on the officers i
just am not in their brain and i don't
believe that anyone would intentionally
the police officers felt that it was
preferable to remain outside while they
heard the gunshots and children being
killed
they preferred that you can't assume
what they did because we don't know what
they did that's because they're lying
through their teeth
but but you saying well they're just
they didn't want to get hurt we don't
know that
like we we don't know what happened to
be clear that's what i'm saying is i'm
not in their heads and neither are you
so absolutely not but i know they're
liars a lot of this story is has has
changed right my understanding is that
cbp the tactical unit that actually went
with the shields were defying orders was
that is that still yes that's an officer
that showed up there and then him and
his buddy they had a shield that they
used specifically but they waited 30
minutes they were given orders they got
there and they were told to stand down
they stood down for 30 minutes then
after those 30 plus minutes this is the
official story again everything should
be questioned because these accounts
have been contradicted multiple amounts
of times but the current story is that
they waited 30 minutes and then after 30
minutes then they decided to disobey
orders um and then go in
with the number of officers and a swat
team who is giving orders to allow the
shooter to kill people well isn't it
that guy that now is now in hiding is
that what it was i think so i think he
was the commander so there was a
protocol a single officer was supposed
to storm in at least that's what i read
and again the stories changed but my
understanding was in march they had done
drills the protocol was you actively
engage even if you're by yourself and it
said something like if if the officer
goes down another officer who arrives
will have to just go in yeah which means
there was a commanding officer giving
orders to multiple agencies saying no
let the shooter keep killing children so
the new york times got its hands on the
actual um like training manual and in
there it basically tells officers you
are going to have to engage in sustained
and yes sacrificial uh engagement with
the shooter and so basically the
training said yeah you might have to die
because these are innocent lives at risk
and so yeah again i mean i don't know
how anybody can make an excuse for for
what has happened and what happened and
i agree with you that we can't at this
point believe anything that is said
about it from the official source
because so much of it has been proven to
be incorrect they have they have spent
hundreds of thousands of dollars in that
small town on riot gear swat gear
and and they posted you know pictures
which they scrubbed on their facebook
page by the way of them standing tough
and strong with all of their ar
equipment and all their body armor but
but again where did all of this money go
to where of all this training go to they
had direct training in that specific
school and there's still so many
unanswered questions that we don't know
about why was that door open what
happened what was there
now they're saying it was closed how did
he get in there where was the school
resources how did he get it how did he
get the truck how do you get the gun
exactly where did he get all that money
from since he of course was allegedly
you know poor what working at a fast
food joint i i mean there's so many
serious questions some people have said
credit cards but the ammo didn't he have
like 600 and 18 year old credit cards
it's going to be difficult especially
with no credit score so
real real quick so i'm sorry uh how many
rounds did he have did it was it 600 i
have no idea about that uh i'm
questioning everything anyway anyway
well my friend ali bradley who used to
work at fox with me in seattle and is an
independent journalist now she was down
covering immigration at the southern
border when this happened so she was one
of the first people on scene and she
spoke to the shooter's grandfather for
an extended period of time and actually
got some insight that no other outlet
had about where he might have afforded
those um those firearms so he had no
expenses in his life
zero he didn't pay rent he didn't pay
his phone bill he didn't pay anything
and he had been working the fast food
job and also working for his grandfather
had didn't have to put out a dime for
anything at 18. so i think a question
for me is how long had been he been
saving and then also the grandfather
told ali bradley that some of his
equipment that he used for his uh work
some heavy heavy duty equipment and
stuff like that had gone missing so i
think there's a possibility based on
that that the kid stole it sold it had
been saving money because he wasn't
doing anything with his life
people in the comments are saying a
thousand six hundred rounds a thousand
so so
what are we season five five six so what
are we looking at five five six is that
that's about about a dollar a dollar
around it depends where you get it you
could get it for 50 50 something but i
want to i want to point out i think i
have an answer to this
a lot of people pointed out that four
years ago it was reported that a couple
kids teenagers were arrested for a plot
at the school
however it was reported these were these
kids were not the same kid here it was
different people
they said the attack was planned for
2022.
here's what i think
it's possible those kids weren't the
only ones planning it
and that they got caught and didn't rat
out their buddies or buddy or whoever
else
what i'm surprised about is if you have
a bunch if you have if you have a couple
kids who four years prior say in 2022 we
are planning this
there it is dude gets a job at 16 he has
no expenses he works fast food and puts
all the money in the bank account all of
a sudden he's got enough money for this
stuff right after two years
it sounds like he ordered the weapon
previous prior to uh before his birthday
and then had it delivered so he could
pick it up two days later i think it's
possible this kid was in on that plot
from 2018 and they didn't catch him so
why didn't police knowing that have any
kind of surveillance precautions
considering they had arrested kids
planning this four years ago yeah not
only that but there was a lot of warning
signs there was the torture of small
animals there was the the cutting
of self like any hallmark signs of a
troubled person who's going to lash out
and hurt other people there was a lot of
that where did our
multi-billion dollar nsa spying
organization go to that tracks trace and
databases almost every single thing we
do to the point where nsa agents have
collections of of people's personal
wiener art uh that they that they are
are known to share and trade with each
other where is the vast surveillance
state that promise that would keep us
safe from terrorist attacks and mass
shooters that would prevent them if we
just give them a little bit of our money
if we just give up a little bit of our
liberty if we allow them to look in our
phones if we allow them to look in our
in our laptops if we allow them to look
into every personal detail of our life
where is the national security
surveillance state when we need it
supposedly that was supposed to stop all
of these they're nowhere he posted
pictures of dead cats in a bag exactly
what other proof do you need that this
was a troubled crazy individual that has
a history of self-harm and the ability
to harm others well let's let's talk
about what the government promises we
have this story from cbs how one
lawmaker wants to curb gun sales a 1 000
tax on semi-automatic weapons before we
read the news i'd like to give a shout
out to our good friend michael malus
with this quote all i'm asking for is
the right to the same weapons that i
paid for the taliban to own yeah bravo
good sir i completely agree well this is
the ukrainians and the and the mexican
cartels and let's let's forget all the
you know uh dictatorships in latin
america that we financed and we funneled
money through through iran contra i
could keep going by the way we do a skit
where it's like a guy talking to obama
and he's like mr president did you give
a bunch of those a bunch of these
high-powered rifles two cartels yes i
did uh can i have one no you can't yep
that's it yep everything
very quick very good that's a very good
obama but again the us government
literally is one of the chief exporters
of weaponry in the world but but also
not for us though but yeah yeah but but
not just not just the afghanis let's not
forget isis uh radical jihadists inside
of syria that literally had the latest
u.s uh uh you know technology uh gear
weapons yeah
toyota trucks uh that were given to them
radical islamists were armed to the
teeth uh yeah hygiene in the 1880s let's
talk about this new story cbs says one
house democrat has a novel idea for
curbing the sale of automatic weapons
like ar-15s blah blah blah the proposed
bill places a 1 000 excise tax on any
type of semi-automatic firearm pushing
up the price of the military-style
weapon beyond the means of many
potential buyers fake news cbs i just
want to shout out when these journalists
write garbage nonsense military style
hunting rifles are identical it's just
it's ridiculous nonsense but i just want
to mention
right away
if you increase the cost of these
weapons by a thousand percent crime will
get worse yeah because all of a sudden
your five hundred dollar handgun is a
five thousand five hundred dollar
handgun and boy can people make money
off that also it mentions many potential
buyers we priced out well that's a
convenient way of saying that these rich
political leaders who are proposing
these kinds of things will still have
armed securities who work for armed
security organizations that can afford
this kind of thing they'll be able to
purchase these weapons to protect their
families you will not be able to
what they're saying is because it's a
revenue measure it can bypass the
filibuster and get past the simple
majority yeah they think they can do it
via reconciliation i will say kudos to
them i'm shocked they hadn't thought of
this earlier it's actually kind of
ingenious because they're not actually
preventing you from buying any sort of
they're not they're not taking your
rights away for weapons but they're
making it more expensive they did this
already with the nfa so this is just
them saying let's let's apply
to standard semi-automatic weapons the
same rules that apply to select fire
rifles well you talked about this a
couple episodes ago with the 72 hour
waiting period for background checks if
you just get rid of that and you extend
it you can prevent people from owning a
firearm just by saying that so this is a
very it's a little ingenious i'm
surprised they didn't do it that doesn't
mean i think it's a good idea but you
know i thought about when it comes to
just gun control and all that stuff and
what democrats would do i've said two
things on twitter i don't want to hear
democrats talk about gun control in
seattle at least in washington state
until they do two things acknowledge
that it was wrong for uh
riders up at chop to hand stolen rifles
out of the back of a trunk of a car
which they never condemned and then two
until they stop cutting deals with
people who commit gun crimes in
washington state there's so many people
who commit crimes actual criminals
commit crimes with a gun who then get a
sweetheart deal um you know some plea
deal with prosecutors and then you know
politicians turn around and say that
they want gun control the only thing i
have an issue with in that story about
chop was the stolen part i think people
have a right to keep and bear arms if
someone if they had legal weapons and
they were handing them out i don't see
an issue i i think there there are
issues with you know political
extremists who are armed and killing
kids like they did in chop but i think
i think we have a problem with the over
regulation of weapons as as a as a
pathetic attempt to stop people from
getting them which it clearly doesn't
what i'm saying is if you've got this
guy rasimo and the warlord of chop who's
opening up the trunk of a car handing
out rifles to people who didn't look 21
to me
and you don't have politicians in the
city of seattle condemn that yet at the
same time they're pro-gun control that
that's ridiculous we make i make i make
this point all the time but luke just
made it earlier that the m1a is banned
in maryland but at the scar 20s for
those that are familiar like they're
basically the same caliber weapon but
one is like an older one's a newer it's
just
actually let me put it this way the
people who know nothing about guns
trying to regulate them is their
achilles heel
36 states have permit-less open carry 25
of constitutional carry florida is set
to be the 26th and all of that expanse
of gun access is happening because the
people arguing against it are like we
got abandoned you're 15 and you're like
it's meaningless it's not going to
happen fine whatever as they're arguing
for more weapons for ukraine by the way
yeah exactly no no so i just want to
make this point they don't know much
about guns but they know one incredibly
important instrumental thing which is
that guns allow you to protect yourself
that is why we see this constant cycle
all right this this has begun
probably two three years ago and expect
to see it continue to repeat they riot
they say it's okay for them to burn down
your city and threaten your life rides
cool down we need to take your guns when
you take your guns then they ride again
or they threaten to ride again then as
soon as that calms down they need to
take your guns right just a couple weeks
ago they were they were threatening
insurrection over the supreme court
potentially overturning roe and then
they're going to ask you why do you need
an ar-15 well because the dominant media
culture and virtually every political
leader in this country who aligns
themselves with the status quo isn't
trying to get themselves in trouble all
the big tech companies sanction your
violence against me so yes i do want to
be able to protect myself and my family
before the show started i actually
posted a meme of fidel castro and
there's there's the question what can
you do with a population after you
disarm them and then castro's laughing
down there anything i want and that's
the story of history that's the story
that has happened throughout all of
written recorded history that we need to
understand here i think it's important
for people to be able to defend
themselves because who are you going to
rely on the yuvali police department to
be there for you during critical moments
and times no they're going to arrest you
handcuff you if your child's getting
shot
oh no
no no no no your ability to defend
yourself is absolutely crucial and
important and it terrifies people that
you could defend yourself that you could
stand up for yourself and this is why
they're putting out all the stops trying
to take away that ability from from you
and so i want to make two points about
that so what we saw at uvalde is
basically what gun control advocates
push for without realizing it they want
to put you in a position where the
police spend their time and energy
disarming you and preventing you from
protecting your loved ones while maniacs
still run around committing heinous
crimes and that's exactly what's going
to happen if there's more gun control
just like there
that is what gun control does and also
they constantly point to countries like
australia and they'll claim look the gun
ban in australia worked well not really
gun crime was plummeting in an identical
rate before the gun ban but this is even
more important but hold on but now do
venezuela now do mexico exactly also
also as soon as the australian gun ban
occurred they said look australia isn't
a tyrannical nation as if our argument
is it would happen overnight but then
after a couple years look under the
covered regime australia has literal
concentration camps they are
concentrating if you are placed in a
holding facility without a trial without
due process without due process and you
are forced to stay there that is in a
camp that is a concentration camp they
literally have those in australia after
banning guns because you can't do that
to an armed population the definition of
a concentration camp i believe from the
holocaust museum was
a place where
uh concentration camp was a place where
people were held without due process
without charge or trial so when the
government comes and takes people and
puts them in a secure facility where
they're not allowed to leave that was
the the base definition so there were
indigenous people in australia who are
rounded up
under kovitz suspicion and sent there
and they were trying to escape climbing
fences i want to pull up a couple images
for you guys so that you can uh because
i i'm going to assume a lot of people
don't know a lot about guns and i'm not
going to pretend to be a gun expert here
but take a look at this image right here
this is the uh this this looks like a
hunting rifle that's that's the way that
it's often described by people on the
left they say they say oh you know take
a look at this it's a hunting rifle
that's what you should have let me show
you this image right here that's a scary
assault weapon look at that it's got the
pistol grip and that scope on it oh man
oh geez yeah the first one is the m1
garand literally used in war the second
one is a 450 bushmaster hunting rifle
they have no idea what they're talking
about again i'm not going to pretend to
be an expert on this one i can just
point out right away that they have no
idea what they're talking about here's
the best part someone in the super chat
said hey tim pull up a ruger mini 14.
functionally the same as an ar-15 but
they don't want to ban that one oh i'm
sorry that's a hunting rifle you know
why it's got a wood a rootstock with the
rifle grip these people have no idea
what they're talking about but you know
what as i sit back and they regulate
things that make no sense i'm like okay
whatever dude
i want to point something out to you
guys
when when i saw this meme and they were
like
oh this is a it showed a picture of what
looked like a bunch of m1s and it was
like these are weapons made for hunting
and then it showed a bunch of pistol
grip you know rifles that these are made
for killing people
and they were talking about gun control
and saying see this is why we should get
rid of these i'm like
do you think that bullets intended for
humans work on big game or deer
do you think that a deer is a larger
creature than a human okay so it stands
to reason that
typically you will want something more
powerful for hunting right as opposed to
combat
i i love it when i'm talking to people
and i'll show them you know like the
ammo we have when we go to the range or
whatever and they'll see a nine
millimeter round or a polymer tip 450
bushmaster and i'm like which one's the
weapon of war
and then people don't know how i'm
trying to trick them so they typically
will be like uh it's going to be the
little one isn't it because i'm like yes
because the big one is for killing deer
which are bigger than people so when
they talk about you should only have
things for hunting oh okay great now
we're going to some lunatic was going to
go out with with slugs 41 mini slugs in
a ksg25 these people have lost their
minds well they never had them in the
first place this stuff roused me up and
i'm not even a gun expert mind you i'm
sure you guys in the chat can correct me
on a lot of this stuff and talk about
how how it's even worse than i'm saying
biden says you just need a shotgun right
nine millimeter
long out of someone i went we went to
the gun shop the other day and they had
they had you didn't invite me i'm a fan
you weren't here
i was getting a 12 gauge and they have
they have a 12 gauge with a rotating
magazine tube it has four magazine tubes
i think it holds 25. and the guy at the
shop is like this one you're gonna your
shoulder's gonna be hurting after this
one man and i'm like yeah i know but you
know it looks cool so i want to get it
and then i'm like isn't it funny that
joe biden is telling people to get
shotguns which are harder to use
they have no idea they're talking like i
i i i'm i'm
reluctant to talk about what would what
would actually happen if some of these
crazies decided to use hunting weapons
these people are so dumb they keep
regulating things that make guns more
dangerous
you know exactly they go off but you
know you don't need uh you don't need x
amount of rounds not you don't need an
air 15 how do you know have you ever
hunted in your life you've ever spoken a
hundred dude basically i don't know a
single person who hunts and is in favor
of gun control i'm sure there's some
somewhere well they're called
unbelievably rare yeah well also
in washington state they banned uh
high-capacity magazines which they set
at 10 rounds which for anybody who knows
guns isn't really high capacity it's a
low capacity when you buy a weapon it
comes with a 30 an air 15 will come with
a 30 round mag for five yeah ten rounds
is not high capacity but you know
there's an argument i have a friend who
survived the vegas shooting so um and i
just had around my podcast the other day
and you know we had a nice conversation
about where she's at and what she went
through and i can't even imagine or put
myself there and she was one of the
people who got through this 10-round
high-capacity magazine and one of the
points she brings up is well if you're
you know people say you need to defend
yourself in your home you don't need you
shouldn't need 10 bullets it's like wow
i probably wouldn't need 10 bucks it's
like i can't hit anything and it's like
i don't want to i don't want to risk
needing 11 or 12 bullets i mean i'm not
a gun person i don't own any guns but we
have you know guns in our home but and
there's there's so many unanswered
questions about that vegas incident that
again was brought up initially it was
one of the largest mass shootings and
then the corporate media just dropped it
stopped talking about it didn't even
care afterwards it it's absolutely
daunting
same thing with with kenosha yeah
they're like not a terror attack
everybody move on yep doesn't matter it
doesn't fit the narrative doesn't fit
the agenda we can't emotionally
manipulate people to get what we want
out of this so we're just going to drop
it and not talk about it that's
essentially what happened here i
remember also seeing a meme earlier
showing ms-13 gangbangers talking to
each other and one of them's like hey
are we going to the drive-by shooting
today and then the other ms-13
gangbanger looks at the other guy says i
can't i didn't get my gun permit today i
can't do that
so this is this is how people think the
laws are going to work here they're
going to be affecting the the the people
who don't respect the law in the first
place no it's going to affect
law-abiding citizens anybody who's
paying attention knows this is just
about
disarming the population it has nothing
to do with preventing any of these these
these shootings or crime or anything
like that and you know it's crazy
because now they're coming out and
they're like 10 mass shootings over the
weekend and i was like oh now you care
about chicago yeah please dude exactly
chicago the the gun-free zone the place
with so much restrictions on people's
ability to defend themselves where
criminals know that there's going to be
people there who can't do anything if
you put a gun in their face because they
can't defend themselves when they attack
them so then you watch these videos out
of brazil man and it's crazy yeah where
like there's that viral video where the
the guy walks up to the group of women
and he's got a gun and he's like shaking
at him and this woman just pulls out a
gun and shoots him and he just hits the
deck
i watched uh man i watched these
another video where these three guys
break into a house
and you can see the guy like sleeping in
his bed watching youtube or something
like he fell asleep watching youtube
videos and then all of a sudden you see
this woman just walk up with a revolver
bang bang and the dudes jump out the
window
yeah i mean what better way to to be
able to protect yourself than than be
able to have a firearm what you're going
to do by taking firearms away from
individuals is making them potential
future victims i think i just want to
make one more point what's ironic is
these people who will argue that our
brains have just been
completely um you know rotted away at by
gun culture and all the action movies
basically have all the opinions they
have about guns
based on action films like they really
think you just point at the person pull
the trigger you're gonna hit them every
single time and so that's why they ask
questions like why would you need 10
rounds or more look if someone breaks
into your home your adrenaline's going
to be in the dark in the dark it's gonna
like you're gonna be shaking even if
you're well trained it's gonna be a
difficult situation so to sit there go
why would someone need more than 10
rounds i i think uh what is it like
police officers only hit their target
something like 30 percent of the time
and high stress situations and they
train more regularly than your average
citizen how many conversations have you
at home had where someone was like why
didn't they shoot the gun out of the
perpetrator's hand yes
this is my favorite this is my favorite
why didn't they just shoot him in the
leg
what what and hit a major artery hey i
write and kill him that's why i love
when they make the mainstream reporters
go do the assignment where they take the
the training and they have somebody like
shoot him with a fake gun it's like oh
you're dead because you didn't act fast
enough when i was uh beginning my career
in seattle i covered crime and justice
before i switched over to politics and i
made a point before i talked about any
use of force i would have that use of
force done i mean short of being shot
like when um eric garner wasn't killed
by new york police in a chokehold so i
let some police officer on camera choke
me in an lvnr a lateral vascular neck
restraint choke me unconscious
to see what it would be like and i gotta
say i would rather that happen than uh
pepper spray or anything like that
because that's much worse than being
choked out but i think it would be good
for reporters it should be kind of
standard in newsrooms to make them go
through
some of that training that police go
through before they talk about it you
know things like that like shooting and
i think well there are plenty police
officers who would volunteer to choke a
reporter that's what i was going to say
is i'm sure that we could simply program
out city of lakewood police department
they asked me for that video i don't
know where the video went but uh city of
lakewood they jumped at the opportunity
to do that they could stream this on
youtube super chat there's a uh um
another very dangerous attempt at gun
control you see here's what's happening
if you go over to
gasprices.aaa.com the national average
gas price is four dollars and
86.5 percent you see gas is going to be
so expensive you'll be able to buy it
you can't afford the guns so there you
go uh no in all actuality yo gas prices
are nearing five bucks this is this is
apocalyptic but wait it's okay
joe biden is allowing solar panel
imports and he has said that this is a
robust recovery where are those solar
panels coming from oh sorry are they
coming from china china and where's
china
oh yeah
yeah and where's china getting the
minerals this is the big caveat where's
china getting the minerals to to produce
uh those uh solar panels who is it do
you know anyone
no no no no it's another place that uh
we left a lot of weaponry in afghanistan
afghanistan yes there you go comes all
full circles
the the great reset
the destruction of your country yeah for
the internal no i don't want domestic
destruction but but again when we look
at what the government has been doing
here these prices
we're just going into peak driving
season these prices are going to go up
the demand is going to go up it's
somewhere dude yeah with these prices
everything else is going to go up it's
not just paying at the pump it's not
just paying for gas your groceries every
other item is going to rise in price
because of this domestic energy policy
that is shooting itself in the foot and
is literally creating this financial
havoc that we are dealing with some
people call this the great reset some
people are saying that we need to
destroy the old in order to build back
better those are the talking terms of
the biden administration
not mine and a lot of other globalist
and world economic forum types they're
the ones talking about this obviously
what's happening here to me is is
absolutely deliberate we are seeing the
financial destruction of the united
states from within the inside and we
still don't even know the actual numbers
of the secret federal reserve bailouts
that are bailing out all the big
corporations that have friends within
their government so things are scary
things are absolutely terrifying
especially when you look at the
financial situation i just want to say
um
gas prices are high in part due to joe
biden
intentional climate change actions
that's just not even up for dispute yeah
because you know it's more
environmentally friendly to import
energy from saudi arabia than it is to
produce it domestically here in the
united states and we get to prop up a
murderous dictatorship that keeps
assassinating children in yemen whatever
whatever is happening after the fact it
is a fact that joe biden said he was
going he was he was campaigning on
climate change he was going to reduce
carbon emissions all of that good
climate change stuff he shut down
keystone he banned uh uh
uh permits on certain federal land
recently banning in the gulf and a bunch
of other areas stopping exploration
stopping discovery this is deliberate
and this is
stated intentionally because of climate
issues and environmental issues and now
gas prices are going up partly due to
that there is a spike coming because of
ukraine that's a fact especially with
europe and especially with us having to
help protect you know europe and and do
we can in terms of their energy we are
being hit by that as well but if you're
wondering why it's getting so crazy joe
biden's going to try and blame vladimir
putin but gas prices were going up well
before putin but the problem is the
mainstream media believes what joe biden
says on it if you if you watch the
mainstream media you think what's
happening right now what's been
happening for the last three months is
because of ukraine right that's what
they're doing it's terrifying well
i mean the problem is people believe in
the mainstream media about anything yeah
but there's a lot of americans who
believe the mainstream the journalists i
don't think believe joe biden well then
why are they putting it out there
yeah they they lie that's why they're
like oh joe biden light again run it
that's it
well have you seen his twitter account
lately
it is like every day he's blaming
someone else for inflation and gas
prices it was meat producers oil
producers republicans trump
uh ukraine putin it's a different thing
every day and i was saying this that joe
biden is a sacrificial lamb they knew
that it was going to be really really
bad so they needed someone to run who
who's not going to win again they needed
a buchanan or somebody and they could
blame it on
on him being old and having cognitive
decline but they won't even admit that
not yet well this is a part of the game
we're arguing about that not the larger
destruction that's happening within the
united states two weeks ago the new york
post had had a very eye-opening uh
article that was titled biden praises
high gas prices as part of an incredible
transition yeah uh so this is this is
his own words and this is the transition
that we're going through right now
because this is deliberate this is what
they've been talking about planning
instituting and doing for a very long
time they don't want you having freedom
of mobility they don't want you driving
cars they don't want you having freedom
in your own personal individual life and
what better way to do that than to take
it away from individuals by making it
too expensive and only allowing the
super rich individuals like john kerry
to fly around in their private jets and
to lecture everyone about how we need to
stop over consuming and have bill gates
buy out the media to promote his fake
meat because red meat is somehow bad for
you when the scientific data
specifically especially when it comes to
beef liver highlights the exact opposite
of that i keep going i'm about to
explode because this is a part again i
think this is all deliberate i i saw a
meme and people are like
when
you know after 9 11
we said oh well no we didn't we changed
the entire way that we board planes and
our respond was like no only for poor
people like if you're rich you get
expedited or you get tsa pre if you fly
on a private plane there's no security
yeah yeah i recently flew on a private
plane it was fantastic it was the first
time i've ever flown and it was a gift
uh i got i got lucky because someone
happened to go in the same way as me and
they're like come on you know take a
ride and i was like okay and we walk
into the airport and they're like hey
i'm your captain right this way and we
just walk straight through it's like 10
feet from the door to the to the door to
the tarmac you walk on the plane not a
big plane it's very cramped but uh
you know the rich people they don't know
they don't got to wear masks they don't
have to deal with the blue glove tsa
agents patting out down putting their
hands where they have no business
placing those hands in there yeah you
know was it elon's playing did you get a
massage
was there a massage table in there it
was it's way too small for that okay so
you know look i'm looking not if you're
uh you know mr epstein let me let me
tell you guys something you know how
much it costs
from so so we we looked into this
from uh dc to austin
round trip private jet
just the base base low lowest rate how
much you think it cost 10 grand how much
do you think it costs a loop
private jet from
austin round trip
15 20
20. 55 000. oh my gosh it used to be way
cheaper a year ago two years ago but the
price of fuel has skyrocketed and
there's a shortage of pilots it's 55 000
and people do it all the time they do
have these things where they do these
pools where you buy like a percentage of
a fleet and then you can use it and then
you got to spend a couple grand per
flight or whatever but that's how much
it costs and guess what part of the
reason it's so high is because the
demand from the wealthy
they are willing to spend that to to
avoid the blue gloves going up and then
them you know grew up in your buttocks
and these are the uh often the elites
who are telling us how important these
security measures are i'm glad you
brought this up luke biden talking about
an incredible transition because it's
interesting i thought we were going to
see a return to normal because that's
what he promised but one of my favorite
things about this is here we see that as
is the case with transgenderism
transition is just a euphemism for
mutilation
fair point um another aspect of this
that i think is worth entertaining and
talking about is that the same time that
he he announced and made this very
important incredible transition
statement he also announced the plan to
set up more bike lanes especially in
city areas and set up more speed cameras
what is that going to do this is going
along with the the un 2030 vision the
world economic forum great great great
you know build back better this is
everything that they've always been
talking about dreaming about and one of
their key plans is to eliminate people's
ability to travel people's ability to
have a car and i i think this is the
larger plan because this is all for
allegedly global warming no it's really
about subjecting human beings uh to
slavery and controlling every aspect of
their existence what better way to do
that than even controlling their their
ability to move around they want you
living in those cities this is a part of
a larger agenda that has been building
up for a very long time and there has
been a huge attack on people's ability
to be able to drive you have to deal
with with inspections you have to deal
with regulations you have to deal with
with uh you know
so many regulations against diesel so
many environmental regulations but but
when we look at the people hurting the
environment they're the ones getting you
know a lot of the support a lot of the
tax money a lot of the government
socialism that goes directly to them
everyone else gets screwed it's paying
the ultimate price and i think this is
only going to get worse and i think this
is
not an accident that this is happening i
think this is deliberate lock step and
barrel every step of the way they are
pushing for humanity's total enslavement
and taking away people's ability to
drive is going to be one of those key
elements that they need to get rid of
well
biden is furious that he's trailing
trump in the polls erupted over being
kept out of the loop on baby formula and
is trying to avoid being compared to
jimmy carter no he's like worse than
jimmy carter
don't worry joey won't compare you to
him you're worse
there you go notice they didn't have to
keep him out of loop on like adult
diapers right he knows what those
numbers are
yeah he's like what's the stock on adult
diapers man well there's actually some
very interesting comparisons to jimmy
carter's administration to the biden
administration especially to what
happened in the 1970s especially with
what happened geopolitically uh with a
lot of very similar troubles that people
have to deal with then that people are
also dealing with now um and i think
especially if you look at the baby
formula shortage another problem of two
big government its wic program it's over
production it's over reliance on one
particular corporation that probably has
ties to the government
again a lot of these problems go
directly towards the central planners
that think that they could control every
aspect of your existence and because
they do they make a lot of problems for
you i think these problems are
deliberate and they're only going to get
worse from here you guys want trump to
run again
man i kind of do because i'm not so
convinced desantis is going to clean
house
you know so like a couple months ago i
was saying i would prefer desantis
because he's he's younger he's he's got
more tact and everything but just with
how crazy things have are getting i'm
kind of like
i think desantis would get in and try
and hold on
i think trump will get in just clean
house he's going to fire everyone i have
i i have the opposite approach i have no
trust in trump at all i think he was
totally infiltrated and totally acted
for the deep state and and made the
situation worse for a lot of people
operation warp speed uh is is one of the
hugest scam and so much uh scams that
were running on the american people so
many mistakes that's just my perspective
i just 2024 is going to be fascinating
because come on do you think
kamala harris because bine's not running
again right
no way there's no way there's no
but hopefully pretend he is they would
have to announce within the next few
months if that's the case because they
got to start lining up the primary pool
for next year yeah but you don't think
they're so identity obsessed you don't
really think democrats would allow
anyone to challenge kamala harris do you
i don't you look at her poll numbers she
is extremely unlikable but who wants to
be the democrat who tries to tries to
push out a woman of color well well no
here's a question though it depends on
whether the mainstream media feels in
the dnc feels that this candidate who's
running against kamala is useful to them
because if that's the case then all the
horrible things kamala has said and done
are going to be fair game and the media
is going to allow people to discuss them
i i see maybe even michelle obama stacey
abrams who's a bilderberg member by the
way i see all of them making prominent
moves uh in this buddha judge i think
he's also going to be another prominent
individual that they're propping up here
as well uh so i think we're going to
keep an eye on all of them but um i i
think the united states is a sinking
ship and i i don't know who would want
to want the job at this at this juncture
because you're literally going to be in
charge of something that's
that that people are not going to be
happy with in the in the near future
look i mean if pete buddha judge can
give birth he can save the country
pete buddha judge doesn't have the x
factor he doesn't know gavin newsom
looks like a mannequin oh not gavin
newsom he looks like he's he's
michelle obama but she she's like
apparently never going to do it
washington governor jay inslee he got
like one percent the first time around
right oh yeah yeah whitmore she's very
popular in michigan
and that california yeah
that california guy what's his name that
eats at that very fancy restaurant
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that guy no
he looks like a mannequin yeah he does
he's very pointy botox sharp just looks
like he's made of plastic booty judge
has a lot of cia connections so i i
still see him being promoted and
prompted up and i think he's going to be
a contender at least he can string a
sentence together yeah well he's yeah
trendy and you know
he has all the he he doesn't have the x
factor but but i do see him uh being
promoted prominently in the next
upcoming election that's how i just see
it sorry i derailed the conversation no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no no no no no no no no no no that's
fine fair point um it's fine we're
we're in a huge mess with this
administration and who's going to come
clean up the pieces absolutely no one
and you need to be personally
responsible for yourself in my opinion
my perspective and i might be wrong and
it's okay if i'm wrong is that uh if you
believe a politician is going to help
you out you have victim mentality um no
one's going to help you out no one's
going to come and save you
yourself is going to help us and it is
alexandria ocasio-cortez
aoc is criticizing democrats refusal to
use the word latinx despite divide over
the term many democrats worry the term
latinx alienates voters of latin
american descent aoc don't stop don't
stop keep keep keep on going tell them
all to keep saying it please please your
advocacy is so important helping
republicans win in in the midterms
didn't you just come out as native
american yes yes
yep nope just uh she's trans racial
mm-hmm so there's the thing about the
tanks i've said this before part of the
reason the left feels it's so important
for folks to start using this phrase is
because to name a person or group of
people is to assert ownership over them
and that is how they view the hispanic
community they believe that they're
their owners and handlers just like they
feel they are the owners and handlers of
every single other minority group they
claim to speak for now the latino
community does not use this phrase they
don't like that phrase the polling has
made it perfectly clear but these
leftist colonists are going to do every
single thing they can to force their
bizarre gender ideology onto this
culture i think they know that they have
to work their way in there and really
destroy the hispanic understanding of
family life by subverting their
understanding of gender roles because
they know that given the
catholic culture of many of these
nations
they are likely to be more socially
conservative in the future and they
could even become republican voters
i think that's the fear so they need to
do every single thing they can now to
subvert that culture as much as possible
that's what this term is well you look
at destroy their understanding of sexual
relationships destroy their
understanding of the differences between
men and women you look at south texas
and uh
things are not looking good for
democrats latino voters are voting
republican you look at florida
yeah november is going to be wild do you
think that i mean like seriously when
when um you know churches get torched or
when the holy mass is interrupted over
roe being overturned how do you think a
mexican catholic feels about that like
how do you think that voter block is
going to respond they they are going to
do everything they can to strip these
cultures of their identity
it's going to be interesting i mean
there's going i think there's going to
be a lot of surprises before november
i i think there's a lot of more
instability than we even realize right
now i think financially this is going to
be the bigger kind of picture here
that's going to affect a lot of people's
decisions especially at the voting uh
booth but
it it's it's really just just
fascinating that there's so many
problems there's so many things going
wrong but but we're talking about latinx
like that's just
this is just crazy augs is going to be
lit
august oh yeah yeah the the the fall so
we're going to be getting into the fall
harvest season so we're going to be
running low on food there's not going to
be new food or it's going to be
seriously depleted because of the lack
of fertile fertilizer in spring there's
going to be diesel shortages no diesel
means even if they have the food they
can't bring it to you it's going to be
10 bucks a gallon in california and
probably in a bunch of other places
we're about to break five dollars a
gallon as it is
but uh hopefully aoc keeps criticizing
democrats who don't say the word the
thinks yeah keep it up
maybe tim we could solve all these
problems by by calling people
electronics
i want to make sure i pronounce it
correctly you know i just want to make
sure you don't pronounce it
it's a horrible
we had a progressive on this show
recently and when i asked him why the
green new deal had a bunch of stuff like
free college for marginalized people and
healthcare he's like because that's
who's affected first and i'm like that
doesn't solve anything having to do with
the climate crisis it's like we want to
solve climate change so we're going to
give college to to minorities i'm like
what does that do about carbon emissions
nothing but you can't point that out
because then you're racist you're racist
i guess
you're racist against the latinx there
was a meme i saw and it said
when gas prices go up they feel like a
wind turbine and it's like the price for
running the wind turbine didn't and then
i responded with like they used
petroleum-based lubricants
like what do you what do you think what
are you talking about of course the
prices went up the price for everything
goes up
i don't know what that what what they're
doing i can only say this the one thing
that it seems to be is that the country
is being gutted and burned to the ground
deliberately on purpose not by accident
they try to make it look like it's an
accident they're like oh no it's just
some competency well i mean the actions
they take that are burning the country
down are completely deliberate
absolutely i would i would assume a lot
of the path to hell is paid with good
intentions absolutely i think there's an
element of that as well but i think
there's also just organizations being
like well let's let's make these people
believe that they're doing the right
thing let's let's push this agenda here
let's let's let's actually you know
rearrange things in a way that's going
to work out for our personal benefit so
i do see people kind of waiting behind
the scenes pushing a lot of these
agendas and narratives that do play a
bigger role that we don't even realize
immediately but then later down the line
we're like hey we're looking around like
hey there's only bugs to eat here hey we
only have a pod hey we only have a vr
headset hey hey we can't go out of our
house we don't have a car we can't
afford a car we can't even drive a car
um
so i do see this kind of larger element
that we're slowly creeping into which is
a technocratic nightmare and i think
it's worth calling out i i think the
this news especially with elon musk and
twitter is a lot bigger than we even
realize i think there's a lot on the
line here um and it's and it's let's
just say it's not a boring time to be
alive it's very interesting and uh i i
think it's only going to get a lot more
interesting
there's this point you made earlier tim
that the road to hell is paved with good
intentions and in many ways that's true
but you know bad intentions don't pave
the road to heaven and we do live in a
culture unfortunately where many of
those at the top really do have very bad
intentions and it might not necessarily
be that it's their goal to destroy the
system but they do want to enrich
themselves at the expense of everybody
else and they also want to hook their
friends up and demolish whatever part of
the culture it is that happens to bother
them and that's going to have
consequences that not even they realize
it's going to get really bad so let's
use the last few minutes for super chats
to talk about this technocratic
hellscape uh just have some fun because
earlier earlier today i went to this ai
and i asked it to make images of donald
trump joe biden nancy pelosi so we
pulled it up again and before the show i
asked this ai to generate some images
for me
and i'm going to show you these images
because they're hilarious and i hope you
guys enjoy them it's from the new avatar
movie yes so i said i would like to see
an image of tom cruise and this is what
it gave me for those are only listening
you know i it'll only be a few minutes
i'll describe it it is an orange
background with a blue skinned man
that could kind of look like tom cruise
but it's not adam driver jake dylan look
at this yeah
yeah yeah he's got a bunch of he's got
too many teeth
i mean kind of a babe though
he's like he's like a you know model
looking kind of guy all right let's go
to the next one i said bill clinton all
right you guys ready for this here's ai
it looks like guy fieri he looked yeah
about to take
[Laughter]
right on a private jet
private island you guys ready for this
one an ai generated bill gates
here we
go i asked for that one i don't know
what this is yeah what's the bill
portion of that is it like saint peter
it's like the kremlin or something
it's not a person no because i don't
know who's next you guys ready jeffrey
epstein are you guys ready for ai
generated jeffrey epstein there you go
that's not right
i mean it's pretty close that's probably
what he looks like now after the
reconstructive facial surgery they were
trying to figure out how to
reconstructive facial surgery so they
ran it through the ai and they made this
somewhere in the world right now there's
a guy looking exactly like that be like
they're on to me are you guys ready for
the best form this next one is the best
one donald trump jr
are you guys ready for this
i'm warning you now you guys are going
to lose it when you see an a.i generated
donald trump jr you ready for this here
you go
what on earth
it's the spoon that gets me it's got a
spoon it's it's okay first of all it it
looks more like alan west than donald
trump jr yeah it does for smooth skin
there's something wrong with the chin
but it is a black man with a spoon in
his mouth
and like a sushi sashimi napkin bib are
you just like he's rich he was born with
a silver spoon in his mouth is that what
we're seeing i don't know i don't know
how this is are we sure we're not
looking at hunter biden's art i don't
know this is kind of what it looks like
all right nah this one you guys are this
one might scare the child this one's
going to scare the kids nancy pelosi
yeah but she always does yes yeah she
does true here's nancy pelosi
skin suit yes
i think she looks better here than she
does in real life
it looks like a skin a nancy pelosi skin
suit look at that hand look at the eyes
there's like
what is this it's what is going on that
is so creepy yeah
i will not be taking over anytime soon
all right all right now for the people
on the show you guys ready for a good
one
luke rodkowski is first yeah here is a i
generated luke rodkowski
sort of got the eyes right yeah yeah but
like the noses should be a lot bigger
it's like you and brandon ruth combined
probably yeah that i don't understand
like the hair is wrong like what it's
not bad this is all right who's next
this is adam this is the next one the
next one i think is sheamus in about uh
two years
you guys are going to love sheamus you
ready
are you ready for sheamus famous in two
years
i can see it fat bastard i know i think
it looks kind of like me i really could
see it i guess that's it i see it it
looks like you're like no but it's got
like thanos chin yeah and joe biden
associates it's like joe biden and
thanos yeah exactly that's that's
sheamus
uh who's next lydia lydia's was just
like an ai yes i look like the lady from
the closer and like one of your eyes is
smashing creepy eyes
but this is kind of weird because it
just looks like it just looks like a bad
like a badly drawn person no it looks
like it was cheap and trying to disguise
itself as well i know it does yeah
eyeballs and now for the best one
timothy poole
are you guys ready for this
here we go it's literally a swimming
pool
that's what the that's what the ai made
the ai literally just made us famous
i wish there was a beanie on it it's the
timbit yeah
that's it yeah just like bill gates if
your name is a common noun you cannot be
ai generated what if you put an e at the
end so if you if you follow my twitter
twitter.comtimcast you can see
where i
made an ai generated image of joe biden
sniffing a little girl
joe biden and donald trump fused
together as one person that's the worst
a couple of bonus joe bidens
yeah that was fun the joe biden sniffing
the little girl is my favorite but it's
like it's weird it's not it's it's just
his face is smashed and like there's not
really little girls like a weird
mashed-faced pig looking thing yeah i
won't be able to sleep tonight if you
show it again
i don't even want to see it again no
it's crazy it's on twitter the nancy
pelosi was good actually maybe i can
pull it up if i just go to twitter
go to my oh yeah you know what i'll just
i'll just i'll just pull it up here
we're on twitter let's see we got here
we go
oh my gosh ai
joe biden sniffing a little girl ai
generated image what look at this oh man
so the ai created that image yes you
made it an a.i made this image wow yeah
here's a couple of joe biden bonuses
it's melting
here's donald trump and joe got infused
as one person yep that's actually pretty
legit that one's good it's pretty good
here's nancy pelosi
dude why are her hands always weird she
looks great i don't know dude she needs
all the hands to hold all the money
she's getting from the stock market
that's true that's true here's joe biden
ai
and then the donald trump age
yeah what's with like his hand on his
shoulder like that's happening
frankly
talking about me it's like they were at
the madam madam how do you say that
and then it melted yeah that's exactly
what it looks like
all right everybody i don't like that
that's uh that's ai but uh we're gonna
you should have the the ai um
draw a super chatter at some point
the ai what draw super chatter you know
oh like one of their names or one of
their names but the issue the issue is
that unless they're really really famous
it just gives you random images
like i don't know i think i thought luke
and i looked pretty good you looked
pretty good too bro i was a swimming
pool yeah exactly swimming pools look
great looking good yeah all right
everybody if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and become a member at
timcast.com we're gonna have a members
only show coming up at 11 p.m you don't
want to miss it let's read the super
chats from all of you guys what do we
got
all right
lethal 5670 says have you heard much on
the dems proposal for a 1 000 tax on
ar-15 style weapons yes we talked about
it
matthew hammond says please make milo
your press secretary marjorie taylor
green
all right
michael allio says now that luke is back
i can finally stop puking
good finally and i can start
raymond g stanley jr says luke didn't
waste a second switching his background
in fact before the show it like we're
hammering insane there's a little
confrontation that happened um it was
great
we had to
there was a physical altercation between
me and someone on this show
and um
all right
what do we get
dominic camarada says who's this luke he
him
okay
a jones says i'm afraid if y'all get
sweated again that roberto will fail to
keep his cool roberto is off at for
damastan roberto jr yeah roberto junior
sent him to boarding school
roberto's was sent to the the penal
colony for abusing women australia
well freedom stan
all right
rice e says it's 5 and 20 cents for a
gallon of gas by me in wisconsin it's
479 here
wow like six in seattle yeah dude yikes
raymond g stanley jr says tim my marine
corps has become a corporate shill
all americans should be proud every day
they bent the uh the bent knee speaks
volumes of the leaders admonish them so
my brother said yeah
omg puppy says it is not just that
twitter serves the democrats it is also
used by the ned and cia for
international operations color
revolution etc absolutely yeah many uh
document cases economic hitmen stuff
like that oh yeah
yeah
in q-tel
sam whitehurst says watched a clip of
ben shapiro talking with neil degrasse
tyson about trans people in sports and
he was literally shaking when answering
the question i used to admire him but i
found many of my heroes will lie to save
face well neil degrasse tyson i mean
he's never been that good to be honest
like just listen to what he says and
you're kind of like dude i think twitter
really was bad for neil degrasse yeah
yeah saying a bunch of really dumb
things
salty duckling says i'd like to welcome
back my favorite decaf russian
if it's even better than my uh my
favorite no i can't say that on twitter
you cannot say that well i just want you
all to know it is a slur against my
people right whisper to me later uh
famous
and uh i'm polish
no that's i think that's what he was
saying i think he's decaf russia yeah i
think it's dario
i love it if i would get offended i
would be offended yeah there was nothing
decaf about you tonight don't worry
that's true that was not
okay so what is this someone is someone
just posted the lyrics to smash mouth so
don't delay act now supplies are running
out allow if you're still alive six to
eight years to arrive and if you follow
there may be a tomorrow but if the offer
is shunned you might as well be walking
on the sun tell what it feels like
well well there you go thanks for the
smash mouth yeah always valuable smash
mouth all right a lot of people saying
luke luke luke is back luke is back
what is a what is a luke's shaft cam
that's a great question i have seen it
mentioned i'm assuming it is what i
think it is
i'm sorry brandy our chat is no please
describe to me what a no it's like
oh it's a it's like a flagpole ian shaft
yeah
exactly the same our chat's wonderful i
think you might be too wholesome
[Laughter]
don't look it up don't do it i'm not
going to google that on your wi-fi
[Laughter]
the chat is blowing up with people
laughing
oh man
oh that was good never been called
wholesome i like i like coming here i'm
wholesome here yeah it's really bad here
waffle sensei says the uvalde cops are
just a result of a castrated nationwide
police force who is so afraid of
stepping one toe out of line that they
were more afraid for themselves than
these children's lives it's too late
cops should go
crazy
go where
different jobs different jobs richard
adams says great journalism about seth
rich subject there is a difference
between negligence and enabling by the
way the shooter was in contact with the
fbi in uvalde
i think that was buffalo there was a
those uh retired fbi agent that was on
the forum that was in communication with
them yeah i heard a rumor that the
uvalde shooter was speaking to someone
they could not identify there was rumors
that they were on the same chat room i
haven't seen that verified yet
we got lots of crazy stuff out there
don't believe everything you read hey
man says you cannot buy guns on credit
false you absolutely can i do it all the
time why would you not be able to yeah
that's weird in fact i only buy on
credit i just pay it off every you know
after every after uh you know every
period or whatever
let's say a baked cup says 1600 rounds
and magazines for all of them that's a
lot of money not to mention a 700 optic
and two 2k rifles i mean yeah even if he
was saving up that much money i don't
think like even if he was saving all his
money i don't know how he gets to the
truck the truck was like 60 grand wasn't
it
yeah it was an expensive truck
especially now if you could even be
lucky enough to get a truck uh because
you know it's very difficult to even do
that now i didn't realize he had bought
a truck yeah he did yeah expensive yeah
nathan bacon baby says tim please use
that daily wire ad money to have makeup
artists get everyone on a show done up
in high quality star trek costumes maybe
try to see each other with them as soon
as you go live
that sounds highly ridiculous and very
expensive
and i think it goes well beyond the
amount of money we got we would have got
paid for the day from the daily wire
really now says military here if you're
a victim you flee if you're a responder
you eliminate the threat it's that
simple if you hear shots that's not
barricaded it's active
of course
wow
that guy says what i wouldn't give to
see luke and brandon tatum in the same
room with a running camera holy hell
luke we've missed you i missed you guys
too it's fine i've been watching the
chat room you guys are on fire i love it
yeah people want that luke shaft cam
i haven't seen those comments today
actually oh i saw many
okay
anyway
we will we will explain that to you in
the fan in the non-family friendly
version over at timcast.com at 11pm
i'm looking forward to it it's gonna be
great brandon freeman says bots on
twitter and fake accounts remember
ashleymedicine.com
it was hacked and almost all the female
user accounts were fake some operated by
employees
what's happening on twitter isn't
reality it's like a bunch of fake
leftist accounts arguing with
conservatives just to keep conservatives
entertained on the platform i mean yeah
it's pretty entertaining
raymond g stanley jr says tim why go
conspiracy when you preach arkham's
razor
arkham that's a good razor i like that
arkham's was it like the joker will
escape
something like that
all criminals will re
engage in recidivism or something like
that what do you mean good sir what do
you mean arkham's razor i need to know
more arkham's razor
poison fist said where's the dash
dashboard cams traffic cams body cams
excuse me
school cctvs or citizen phone footage we
only have 10 seconds fillet of fishy af
though 10 seconds more than we have of
adam lanza
crazy
let's see
now there are eggplant emojis so i
imagine i've got my answer about what
the shaft cam is great
enjoy
let me drink some water real quick i got
nothing to say about that
luke provide comment
don't know what to say about that one
but uh very creative uh commenters i
love the the entertainment chat's a
great place
absolutely that guy says tim
your alec baldwin logic whereas dozens
of mistakes would have to be conducted
in succession to make alec innocent what
if you applied that same logic to
yuvaldi where would that lead you it
would lead to a psychopathic murderer
who bought guns and then went and shot
people i mean the thing about alec
baldwin was that
we know he had the gun we know he was
manipulating the gun we know there was a
live boat in the gun we know he pointed
the gun and i'm saying all of those
things are literally true
then how could you argue it was an
accident
it's the inversion of a conspiracy
theory it's like the alec baldwin story
was literally the media making up a
conspiracy theory alec baldwin was
handed a gun that he was supposed to
have checked that someone else was
supposed to have checked and he pointed
at a woman pulled the hammer back
releasing a live round killing her after
having a dispute with her over pay or
something like that or something like
that happened and
to believe anything other than just that
story right there would be to
be make it into a conspiracy theory
we'll see
all right what do we got more super
chits
ian hall says to the point you are the
militia prepare and be ready
that is true
sergeant buck says seattle is a lost
cause at this point speaking as a near
seattle native
inslee thinks restricting magazine size
to 10 rounds will do something he's only
harming law-abiding gun owners
that is true and correct
like anybody who's got an illegal weapon
and planning to commit a crime is going
to care about breaking another breaking
another law especially something like
that
so dumb
guardsmen nordheim of the tenth first
isn't he says isn't this why isn't it
well he says is it the why can ukraine
get gun's argument a little weak
considering they are actively under
attack from russia
luke well the aspect here that we have
to understand here is that a lot of
these weapons are being sent not tracked
we don't know what hands they're going
into and you could bet your bottom
dollar there's going to be a lot of
black market firearms after this
conflict uh if it ever ends because this
conflict might not end so obviously i
understand your point but the point is
more kind of nuanced here saying
specifically you want those people to
have guns but but other people not to
have guns based on
uh you know your own kind of political
ideology that doesn't really stand
behind a virtue because people should be
able to defend themselves no matter what
the situation is
so that's just my perspective
and comment all right let's give some
more we get some more super chats we got
so many super chats we have so many the
best super chats everybody agrees
hybrid says i'm so glad i can stop
puking welcome back
everyone's just vomiting all over their
keyboards every night they could help
just watch the show it's just so good i
can't stop
i promise it's no joke the pandemic is
over yeah tyrant hunter says hey if they
make guns hard to get i'll just befriend
some cartel members and get some of our
guns obama gave them there you go
there's always one way to do it i guess
i don't think that'll work out too well
for you to be honest
stim bucket says teaching is the answer
not to tyranny accurate information is
almost always better than regulation no
taxation without transparency
were you were you looking up something
to show luke oh somebody wants a brandy
foot cam
even better you don't my feet are not
nice
welcome to our chat chris larson says
the largest producer of eggs in the u.s
was mysteriously burnt down recently
making it the 19th food producer to burn
down this year so the important thing
here is you need to look at every year
the amount of food processing plants or
related plants had suffered some kind of
incident and i don't think the numbers
this year are remarkable
i think what people are doing is they're
noticing and then being like whoa this
looks crazy and it's like it was also
crazy in like 2013 you know so but i
mean
i do think it's fair to point out that
regardless of whether it's normal or not
these things are going to have a
a very serious impact on the already
strained food supply i am going to have
to see what tucker carlson said about
that because he mentioned it shortly
after we talked about it and i forget
what he concluded so i'll check it out
sheamus pot of gold cam yes
[Laughter]
all right nate says tim if that is the
definition of concentration camp
wouldn't that make aoc correct about
what you said about the border no
because people choosing to come to the
border to go into a camp is different
from being taken from your home without
due process
someone trying to enter a jurisdiction
illegally and then being detained is
breaking the law
being detained is part of due process
being in your home and having medical
agents show up and say you're going to
the camp there's no charge no trial
we'll let you know when you can leave
that is being rounded up for a
concentration camp
all right where are we at
i can't read this one
twofoldhundengrunt says if you are old
enough to be drafted you are old enough
to drink smoke vote drive have sex and
own any firearm
yes
and if you're not old enough to have
those things 21 then you should be able
to vote so raise the voting age how
about that
jw dickinson says poor one out for hero
paul hardware's twitter handle dog that
he and his wife rescued long ago was
finally let go
oh
free men die free says the two-way
community doesn't properly address the
commerce clause it wasn't intended to
give broad federal regulatory power and
led to the birth of the atf
oh that sucks
balian says tim i live i live in alaska
and we use 556 to hunt black bear bro
that's right
i'm not saying that people don't use
five five six or nine millimeter to hunt
i'm just saying you have
hunting rounds for a bigger game and
when the left tries making that argument
they don't know what they're talking
about
michael best says hello from auburn
washington i listened to both brandy and
dory monson daily which keeps me sane in
this state full of crazy
happy to help do you know who dory is
yeah he's a good friend of mine he's a
conservative radio host in seattle and
sometimes i feel in for him do you also
know jason rancy i do yeah jason's a
dear friend of mine yeah we've had him
on right yeah we have yeah he's great
he's right i like reading his articles
oh yeah
ethan reed says i think it's i think
it's a read does the fn scar 20s you
speak of not have a folding stock i
think with a folding stock it would be
illegal but you can own an own a what is
it iwi td 12 rotating mags on shotguns
are supposed to be on that list
look at it on msp license port i live in
west virginia good sir i don't live in i
don't i don't live in maryland so i
don't got to worry about any stuff
what did it say
back bald oh says wait until you guys
find out about pistol braces versus
stocks
yes well i know all about them joe biden
was recently trying to make those uh
regulated under the nfa the ideas
there are pistols
that have braces that you can put on
your forearm so when you're holding it
it's easier to shoot
but some people and they shouldn't do
this put it up against their shoulders
like like it's a stock as if they're
using a short-barreled rifle that's a
no-no maneuver you can't do that i don't
know how that works though is that is
that illegal to just do the maneuver
like putting a brace into your shoulder
it's all it's all kind of arbitrary and
how they want to enforce it right so
it's all up to the federal bureaucracy
that is so well and efficient
said no one ever
waffle sensei says remember when
conservatives used to say if you have
nothing to hide then you have nothing to
worry about how the after that work out
now the machine is built to turn on its
own citizenry
yeah well you know
you gotta pay attention ashbush
how do we pronounce this one amal antra
him says i'm in washington state i
decided to get a 458 socom and now i can
put 10 rounds in all of my 30 556 megs
yeah they they work for that right 450
uh 450 458 fit into five five six
we have to look that up
what do we got here
ethan reed says i meant iwi ts12 not on
the list when booked la when looked last
interesting well i don't care for
maryland anyway so
sarah hunter says if only we had more
laws against rape we would never see
another assault ever again ban ramp ban
rape why would we not ban that what the
heck and and murder
murder should be illegal yeah
but for some reason people keep doing it
i mean they see these people violate all
these laws to commit a mass atrocity and
they go do we need more laws
yeah
flutt's q says so an assault weapon is
an item used or designed to cause
physical damage physical trauma which is
used to cause physical damage bodily
trauma so it does mean something so long
as you are illiterate a solomon doesn't
mean anything it's a completely
meaningless term they're like it's a
weapon of war
whatever dude
it's funny because it's like what what
do you think these weapons were for
like of course they're used for hurting
brunch
you
fire at the pan or something no idea
when you're when you're cooking dinner
pirate taurus second half says i have a
friend that was born with one arm he
uses a semi-auto 12 gauge shotgun he
delivers pizza with a manual
transmission car too
yeah well
you could do it
sounds like an interesting guy yeah
christopher says luke is going to be the
new alex jones in 15 years
i mean like we're talking 15 years he'll
be the old alex jones then right you
knew alex jones now though
yeah
that's like a compliment
he doesn't love it
mike williams says the second amendment
doesn't grant americans the right to
keep and bear arms it does acknowledge
americans have the right at birth and
makes it clear the government doesn't
have the right to infringe on that
god-given right that is true it says the
right the right to keep and bear arms
shall not be infringed because it
already exists it's just i suppose if
you're illiterate you would use the um
you would say well-regulated militia
which has nothing to do with the
statement the right of the people to
keep and bear arms shall not be
infringed
it clearly it's clearly saying yes a
well-regulated militia defends the state
therefore the right of the people to
keep arms can't be infringed because the
people have to be armed to form the
militia
but i suppose too many people are
illiterate we're just lying
texas fox says gas prices natural gas
prices are up by over double this year
heating and cooling homes will get
expensive
oh yeah install your solar while you can
here's a funny thing like solar panels
are basically a net negative
but they operate off the grid so
when you get solar on your house you're
utilizing more energy than you're going
to get back but
you know you have it for your house if
the power goes out right that's how it
works
jeffrey grajic says mexico has some of
the strictest gun laws mexico has one of
the highest yearly gun fatalities maxo
has exactly one gun store more gun laws
they have one gun store i'm not aware of
that
but
one one
and where is it i'm not sure in the
middle of the day
it has like three guns wherever the
cartel is yeah where did obama set that
up there's probably a line of government
officials there like asking for a
handout just to get to the next door
brian marzinski says gas in northern
illinois is 5.55
in my area yo that is insane i found
this great title from the la times there
is only one gun store in all of mexico
so why is gun violence soaring such a
great question i wonder what conclusion
they reach
damien masters says jb is using the
defense act for an electricity shortage
are we having brownouts or blackouts or
something gas sure is high though come
august
there's going to be no diesel
so you know what i was saying is like
whoever manufactures electric
big rigs
i imagine their stock is going to
skyrocket you know what i'm thinking
here's my prediction
august is going to come
diesel's going to be through the roof or
if not just within in shortages i mean
because we are we already see some
places that don't have it
joe biden is going to invoke the defense
production act or something and say we
got it we got to get you know 100
million dollars to these these these
companies that make the electric trucks
we got to get we got to get baby formula
and food on the table for for mampa
and then he's going to sign something
and then money's going to be infused
into these companies and their stock's
going to go up well bine was in seattle
not too long ago and he said that he
wants all military uh vehicles to be
electric
right so i wonder who's gonna
get the money on that
tesla could you imagine tesla designing
these like these military rigs ooh
they'd look cool they would all look
weird chrome like they're totally
visible in battlefields and
provide no strategic advantage but
they're really good
i don't know those batteries would that
be like what would happen if it blows up
fire i mean are these these are
lithium-ion batteries aren't they if
they get punctured they're gonna
that would be nuts
all right
w falcon says luke and shim peak tim
cast keep up the good work guys all
right guys i guess i guess we kind of
work well together every now and again i
don't know
maybe we could do it
i do carry the team but we were left
together for a reason c james says check
out engine number one environmental
activists are taking board seats and oil
companies at a time we can least afford
it and dictating policy and they're
gloating about it on twitter let's get a
bunch of vegans at the board of the meat
processing plant perfect and then
they'll be like we're gonna put
soy
in all of the beef instead of beef and
then you're eating soy
just a stye says tim please stop
promoting green energy one wind turbine
use 80 gallons of pao synthetic oil
which is based on crude and that
lubricant has to be replaced once a year
green energy is a lie
crazy
yeah i talked to a bilderberger member
that's an upcoming politician from
europe just a couple just yesterday
actually at the airport and she told me
europe we want europe to go fully green
we support a carbon tax we're not going
to use fossil fuels anymore and i'm like
this is what you want this is what
you're pulling for an act and and
advocating for it she's like yep
that's it i'm like okay wow
lego math again says biden says shotguns
are okay because they don't look so
scary thank god these psycho shooters
don't use more shotguns
the ease with which they could wipe out
rooms and hallways full of victims and
responders without training optics or
even aiming
yep
that's that's that's scary but you know
biden says people should have them
because they don't know what they're
talking about it's so weird yeah
sleeping earthling says how good the
country was doing under trump and luke
really well compared to a lot of other
places
american gun chick says handgun rounds
are horrible
fight stoppers
perps walk through handgun bolts like
nothing ask a rapper
even heart shots have 10 to 30 seconds
to continue hurting folks under 10
rounds is effing stupid
so then what what what would you want
would you want like
buckshot or something like if you're in
your house and you can't have more than
10 rounds no no no i'm saying if you're
in your house and you're like a glock 17
9 millimeter frangible hollow point or
something
i feel like if someone's going to be
able to move through them and still
cause damage like what would instantly
stop them i feel like buckshot would be
good only because especially if you're
dark you have a better chance of hitting
them yeah
if it's in the dark
we'll have to ask an expert someone who
is properly trained on close quarters
combat home defense
josh branson says cast kamala will have
to run against a great uh gay trans
furry woman in the dnc party
eventually but i mean seriously because
no one
wants to you know we just saw that
dallas drag drag kid show they were
grooming children literally and shun
head was like left leftists stop
being scared
to call this out because you're worried
about being called a reactionary
but they defended it and they like
yelled at you on the head about it and
they were like nothing's wrong here
but maybe we'll talk about in the after
show because that stuff isn't not
family-friendly
bonkers says
1 000 ar rounds weighs almost 27 pounds
not an easy thing to be running through
a field to a school caring when he was a
scrawny high schooler 1600 weighs almost
50 pounds yeah we got one of those those
cases with a thousand rounds in it all
in the plastic that's hefty stuff
matthew waddle says tim which is it the
road to hell being paved by good
intentions or hanlon's razor
could be both
incompetent people with good intentions
do really horrible things it's a deadly
combination and malicious people with
good intentions like
i suppose it's paradoxical but you could
people who just genuinely
want to cause pain to others but think
that what they're doing will ultimately
be good
crazy
all right
falcon laser says brandy what does the
average seattle voter think the
documentaries think of the documentary
seattle is dying how many are actually
happy with the condition of the city
uh well seattle's dying was done by komo
news which is the abc affiliate i
thought it was really good of course the
the progressive crowd thought it was
exploiting the homeless and
was cruel so i would say the average
seattle crowd looked down on seattle as
dying as like a piece of right wing
propaganda because como is owned by
sinclair
um but i do think there's a tide turning
the city has gotten so bad uh with
homelessness with crime with with drugs
with mental health issues that you're
starting to see maybe a little more
political will i know our new mayor has
taken a different tune
so it's promising
so let's see people are talking about
the ai stuff that was good fun kind of
gross terrifying good fun
one
evil chef says tim tesla did make an
electric semi-tractor fact check it yeah
i heard about that i was thinking i was
hearing about that
yeah maybe maybe it's a good idea i
don't know
sergeant bucks is a brick a car and a
pointed stick are all assault weapons
assault weapon is meaningless it means
nothing
cornelius buttknuckle says put my
username into the ai image generator no
thank you
maybe
good on that
dung is fun says if they raise the legal
age to use a rifle to 21 that means
anybody under the age of 18 cannot use
the rifle in the military how does that
make sense they will let you use it
while you're in the military but not
when you leave there you go
david sanchez says for your gun doc you
should talk to u.s historian david
barton he's very informative and would
be a great guest on here shim would love
him love y'all
we will check that out
ethan lurker says tim the agency that
collects on us individuals is the fbi if
someone in the nsa collects on anyone
inside the u.s it will lead to them
being imprisoned the document ussid
sp0018 outlines what nsa can collect on
and how they are processed
interesting
what is this
joe wescott says tim say hi to my wife
kristen hello hi kristin
cosmic surgeon says tim says occam's
razor and standalone complex in the same
video
yeah
i don't understand that that makes
perfect sense for sure
little littles pressure washing says hey
tim since starting my pressure washing
channel on youtube i'm noticing similar
channels who have bought fake subs and
views it's good to be organic bro
greetings from us at littletails farm
well people love their their pressure
washroom you know
uh
uh
slavkai nikki says see the luke shaft
cam at lukeuncensor.com love you my
polsky brother
it's where i do my uh segments and
videos and is there a shaft cam there
no all right everybody thank you if you
have not already smash that like button
subscribe to the channel share the show
with your friends and head over to
timcast.com we are going to have a
members only show coming up for you at
11 p.m it won't be family friendly and
we will tell you what a luke chef cam is
at timcast.com
so check it out you follow the show at
tim cast irl follow us on instagram
because we post clips every day follow
us you can follow me at timcast
basically everywhere you can follow me
on instagram and twitter as well randy
do you want to shout anything out oh
yeah i'm um on patreon and locals
patreon.com forward slash undivided
brandycrews.locals.com do weekly podcast
video content would love to have you be
a subscriber
um on twitter i'm on facebook and also
can i end with something corny
um i want to thank you tim because you
know how hard it is to build something
up and i appreciate you giving me a
platform that's very nice of you awesome
absolutely well thanks for coming it was
great um i missed you guys i even missed
this uh angry potato head guy uh
and it's really fun being back i i
really enjoy the conversations here
there's a lot the vibe here the energy
here it's it's very important and i
appreciate you guys being able to listen
through some of my crazy unhinged rants
and conversations um if you want to know
what i'm doing you can check out my
youtube channel youtube.com forward
slash we are change i just released a
very interesting video confronting
bilderberg members and having some very
interesting conversations with them as
they're scurrying away i think i saved
one person's life as they were trying to
you know run across the street they
almost got hit by a car i had to stop
them um from literally falling into a
car because i was asking them questions
they really didn't like that youtube.com
weirdchange is where you could find me
thanks for having me it was a joy and
pleasure it was a joy and pleasure for
you
it was great having you back man um i'm
seamus coughlin i run a youtube channel
called freedom tunes we relay we release
animated cartoons every single week you
guys should go over there and check it
out we have some funny stuff coming out
for pride month also we just launched a
website freedomtunes.com if you want to
support myself the artists who work on
freedom tunes and help us expand please
go to freedomtunes.com become a member
to support us you'll get an extra
cartoon each week there's also five
cartoons up there already and a bunch of
behind the scenes stuff i think you guys
will enjoy
i'm very excited for freedomtunes.com
but i'm even more excited for this
this members only chat this evening
where we learned the secret that brandy
doesn't know so i'm really looking i'm
playing dumb so people will join us
kind of tricking them into it i respect
it it's gonna be awesome it's gonna be a
good chat our after show chats are
always awesome you guys can follow me on
twitter and mines.com at sarah patrick's
as well as sourpatch lids dot me
we will see all of you over at
timcast.com thanks for hanging out bye
guys
you